well ice confirming the suspect accused
of killing a houston area deputy was in
the u.s illegally and had been on the
run for more than two decades let's
bring in texas congressman dan crenshaw
and congressman i know that you were
watching along with us as we watch this
funeral at st patrick cathedral as jason
rivera the fallen nypd officer is laid
to rest today and the nypd commissioner
in her speech getting multiple standing
ovations because she was speaking
directly to them from the heart and she
has their best interest of mine and she
said that the city won't turn their back
on the police officers ever
but you're in houston and we know that
even across the country we've had 27
officers shot and it's the 28th day of
the month this year alone
what are your thoughts what are you
hearing from people there in houston or
more broadly about this
these attacks against our officers
well thanks for having me dana and you
know from watching that it does look
like new york is in for some better
leadership major upgrade from de blasio
that's pretty obvious we need some
similar upgrades here in the houston
area so
as you reported we had three officers
shot this week officer galloway was
murdered by an illegal immigrant here in
this country illegally
the week before that
and um what's the root cause of this
well it's leftist ideology so leftist
ideology fundamentally does two things
it punishes success while accommodating
bad behavior out of some false sense of
compassion and that manifests in lean d
a's lenient judges lenient prosecutors
that are soft on crime and will let
violent criminals out there's the
houston chronicle reported there's well
over a hundred cases
where a criminal a violent criminal was
let out maybe on some kind of low bail
or just let out without bail and then
went on to commit murder not just
another violent crime but murder well
over a hundred cases then this is
happening all across the country you're
seeing crime spike and so
the root cause has left us ideology
we need to address that root cause and
actually put people away in prison when
they commit violent defenses it really
is that simple um and if you really
believed in compassion the left really
believed in the compassion that
compassion would extend to the victims
that keep getting killed whether those
victims are police officers or whether
those victims are civilians
you've seen these secret flights right
under the cover of darkness where
illegals have been flown to different
cities all across america
we're expecting now
in july of last year we had 6500
apprehensions at the border
they now anticipate 9 000
per month in the spring of 2022
and the head of dhs majors was down at
the border talking about some of the
agents and the audio leak some of it
this did not go well i just want to play
a portion of this
specific question coming up after
go back here before you come down before
anybody comes down a senator it doesn't
matter
they
always buzz as many people out here as
they can to whatever other sector it may
appear
that everyday
we know better i know then the
commitment remains and we'll keep
fighting
and let me let me just say you can turn
your back on me but i'll never turn your
back and my back on you you did the
danger appointed
um so apparently that happened uh off
camera dana and i have been wondering
who else is covering this news
you think about it you know turn around
the dial flip it around and if the white
house isn't being asked questions about
it if the administration feels no
pressure to change the policy
seems pretty logical to conclude that
they won't change their policy
no and at this point we're wondering
what on earth are they going to do to
fix this crisis and i do want to correct
one thing that's 9 000 expected per day
9 000 per day correct that's a
completely unsustainable number at our
border that's a that's a that's a crisis
every few hours
you know let's not forget the dhs
secretary under obama said that a
thousand per day in the entire southern
border would be considered a crisis now
you've got 9 000 a day and texas is
especially hit hard by this
and um look what the what they're doing
is is is is beyond comprehension joe
biden is deliberately refusing to
execute his constitutional duty to
execute the laws of the land
all right that that's very clear in
article two that the main the main
purpose of the executive branch is to
indeed enforce those laws so when you're
letting loose single adult males on
buses and giving them plane tickets and
allowing them to go through tsa with
just their arrest warrant as
identification and by the way did they
ever show any identification how do we
even know that those names are real we
truly do not know who was coming into
our country uh this is a national
security issue it's a crime issue it's a
basic issue of sovereignty do we believe
that we have a right to protect our
borders or not do we believe that legal
immigrants have a right to actually be
in the front of the line instead of
being cut in front of every single day
by 9 000 people
you know there's a moral question to
this there's a there's a legal question
to this and and joe biden is
deliberately refusing to is do you
actually just be constitutional duty
right
i misspoke you write about 9 000 a day
um it's just extraordinary it blows the
mind to think that it's been going on
for a year
um listen we've got another speaker at
this funeral in new york and uh
apologize for cutting you off please
come back congressman thank you good to
see you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now